Yes.
Welcome everybody.
We are back.
Thank you for joining us.
Today's episode is sponsored by Quip,
Capterra ring at 23 and me today with us
are two of my favorite people in the
world,
Christina p Thompson.
God bless them.
Today we celebrate the release of
Christina ps,
new special out on Netflix right now.
Featured in the degenerates.
Also touring A.
Christine's be online.com
and Thompson also touring.
Yes sir.
At Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash
tour.
Thank you for saying it correctly.
Well Hey,
it is two or fewer.
I like to get out some of the east coast
people.
They see a tournament.
Yeah,
and I'm always like a different word
that's wrong.
They say tournament tournament.
They say yeah,
like keep me up to be one of those
people.
I have friends from philly that go like,
you're going to stay for the tournament
and I'm like the tournament and I don't
know.
It's a real problem.
I feel like that's not the right word.
I think it's completely wrong to say it
like that.
Am I missing?
But the spelling I guess could lead you
to be like,
yeah,
it's tour.
No men.
So how do you say it?
Tour?
No,
no,
I'm saying I'm talking about it turned
to tournaments to say tournament.
You don't say tournament.
No,
that's insane.
That's a bad.
And we're back and we're back.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Happy.
No,
not November to both of you here.
I'm fucking backed up.
He backed up.
I am.
Do you don't know about?
No,
no,
not November.
I'm assuming.
I've seen sounded some rumblings on the
Internet for sure,
but I mean after.
So you can say whatever the heck you
want after sober October though.
No Jazz November.
It's not happening,
but I haven't just this whole month.
You haven't June.
Not on purpose.
Yeah,
pretty much.
You'll go,
you'll go a seven days in a month
without even trying to think,
well,
here's why you were traveling and I
guess sick.
You don't care if I don't and none of
those things inhibit me.
Okay.
I jerk.
I jerked it maybe the first or second,
but now,
I mean now it's like five days of built.
It's backed up.
You could feel an ache.
I'm kind of feeling empty and when
they're full you mean by the.
By the load side of the,
the girth of the testes.
The,
Hey,
are you serious?
Will agree with you.
She's pretty good at it.
I didn't.
I didn't even know that about myself,
that the shill got a store somewhere.
I'll lean over and be like,
let me slide it in.
And she'd be like,
hold on.
She'll do like an exam.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
oh,
it's been woo,
this is dangerous.
But one of the glues going to come out
like it's been.
Oh my goodness,
that's graphic,
but I feel like I'm kind of short.
I'm feeling kind of aggressive today and
she'll also pick up on that.
She'll be like,
you're that upset about it.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Really honed in on each other's a load
sizes in behavior.
That's amazing.
You've been together for 14 years,
so when he's 10 years officially married
tomorrow.
Oh my goodness.
That's wonderful.
Well,
you guys are truly excellent.
Amazing.
One of the great couples on the planet,
so I'm very,
like I said,
we could work something out though.
For what?
For getting this thing out tomorrow.
Sure.
We'll see.
You can masturbate.
Yeah,
but then it ruins.
It ruins what,
Babe?
The font of of you being like.
That's so much.
Oh,
can I be honest?
Be honest right here.
Now.
I don't think I've gone more.
Oh my God.
I'm trying to honestly think this guy
really jerks at.
That's where he's going to tell me.
I don't think I've gone more than a day
without accumulating maybe since I was
like a day.
Don't look at me.
I mean,
I don't know,
maybe a couple of days,
but you.
For me it's like,
you know,
there's this great.
You guys have seen the Seinfeld about
the competence.
Kramer has this great line that has
resonated with me since I heard it.
She says masturbating.
No,
that has red.
I think about it every day.
He goes,
Elaine wants to join the competition,
and they say that's not fair.
She says,
well,
you know,
masterminds like shaving your legs.
And she says,
I shaved my shaving.
She says,
I shaved my legs and Kramer says not
every day.
That's right.
Right,
right,
right.
Well that's true.
Now let me ask you something though,
because I'm assuming you guys aren't
getting it in every day.
Marital loves.
So are you.
Where do you.
Where are you doing your thing?
Is it the shower bathroom?
Well,
not where you're going to notice me.
That.
No,
I don't keep it a secret then something.
Have you been caught?
Have ever been caught?
Actually,
no.
I cannot wait to catch him.
I've never been called.
I think I was caught once by my vehicle
was under the blanket.
It was more embarrassing than dramatic,
but either will never catch me
masturbating.
Why is that?
Why you buy this?
I don't.
This is the bed detective.
Do you?
Are you trying to walk in now?
The detective's going to come out though
now.
I'm not safe.
You're going to be like in the middle.
We're going to be really close and
you're held me back.
And then just to see her face like Linda
through a door can be in the reflection
of the monitor watching porn.
But you don't care.
You can go a week without even thinking
about it.
Uh,
no.
I mean I think about it a lot,
but sometimes I'll go like,
here's the thing to men,
we got two kids.
One's a real little one.
Yeah.
So like your sleep and,
and you know when you have a busy
schedule,
like we know we were all doing a lot of
things.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's like,
it's literally,
oh my God,
I just got to bed and I'm so tired.
Sometimes it'll be like,
oh,
it's morning.
I could do it right now.
And I will,
um,
or night in the shower,
shower.
And then.
But I'm saying sometimes like that I'll
be like a,
is this going to be a good one?
Or you don't mean.
Because there's ones who were like,
that was a disappointing one at this
point.
They're all disappointing for me.
How has it discipline?
There's disappointing.
That's where you're just like,
ah man.
That was just,
it got.
I mean,
he's just got some of the food through
the system,
but it's not like it.
You know what I mean?
This,
that.
Let me put it this way.
It's just like stale chip.
You jerk off and it's just like.
And then you're like,
all right,
there's no,
there's almost no pleasure.
Like compulsive.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I'm really backed up,
right?
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
Tomorrow we'll do it.
Oh Wow.
Well here you go.
Ah,
yeah.
We have to understand sober October kind
of ruined that month too because he was
exercising six hours a day.
That really fucked me up,
man.
I worked out for almost 4,000
minutes,
which whatever.
That adds up to a lot of minute.
Yeah.
Because it gives you a little recap on
that through the APP and I swear to you
were a lot of times we're doing two a
days like working out in the morning and
then in the afternoon or evening and I
would,
I would fall asleep like into the
deepest slumbered,
which is nice.
It was nice.
Yeah.
But I didn't have the.
No,
nothing.
Should we tell him what happened?
Remember,
remember,
right towards the end of October,
October.
I don't know,
it's just fucking sad.
We went all right.
We went to make marital love and I had
full body cramps and had to stop old
body crap dude.
Like arms hands.
And I was like,
I didn't even tell you this.
I felt some of those cramps before I
stopped.
I was like,
fuck it,
ignore it.
Don't,
don't stop and go stop.
And then when it was to the point where
like,
I felt like I was gonna fully collapsed.
His wife said something.
I have never experienced the whole body
cramps.
I mean what I'm saying,
I had a,
you know,
I've had calf cramp arm,
um,
chat like these were all at once.
That was so dehydrated,
you know,
how was do it seems so intense.
Do you enjoy it?
Do a mean with the sober.
I enjoy fitness aspect of it seems so
intense.
It was intense.
I did enjoy it.
I think it's fun to compete with
friends.
Like it's fun to go like,
Ethan,
I bet I can do this.
I will be.
You Go,
well if you go like I can do it too,
and then like we really are and then I'm
checking on you and you're checking on.
That part's fun.
I think if I was just competing with
like people on the Internet,
I'd be like,
I dunno.
Yeah,
yeah.
What was.
Was there any noticeable effects for
view gloss?
Wait,
are you feeling.
How is.
I mean you haven't even.
I feel like I'll tell you why it ruins
our home life was like where's dad?
Just hiking for eight hours at a like
our son
is crying one day.
Are you seeing fell behind and I bowl
rigs out and shit like that.
And you're like,
what?
Why are we doing this again?
You're all over 40.
Well I'm middle aged in the forties.
It feels good actually.
I'm buying online.
Can we celebrate Ms Dot Sheila though?
And your pregnancy.
I'm dying to talk to you about this.
Have you talked about this a lot on this
show?
But yeah,
there's a lot to say.
I'm sure about it.
We're doing a little updates,
like we had an ultra,
our first ultrasound last week.
That's a cool.
It like a little,
little,
a gummy bear with a heartbeat.
Heartbeat when they do the ultrasound,
I remember I remember separate times
than the lady being like,
do you want to hear the heartbeat?
Like who goes now?
You're saying it's there.
All right.
And then you're like,
yeah,
of course.
And then they're going to do.
You're like,
who doesn't want to hear that?
Like,
okay,
they should be concerned if you set off
a notification.
It's such a cool moment.
So you're feeling great.
Yeah.
I'm not nauseous at all.
I guess.
Weird.
Everyone is like,
oh.
But I,
we've talked about how I've never puked
in my life and in your life.
Never even felt the uh,
almost puke.
Like if you ever almost puked.
I've had this like when you're little,
when you're looking for something or
come up.
Well there's been times I that even
possible.
You mean like indigestion?
Not the same.
You don't,
you don't even know you.
She so doesn't even understand what
puking it.
I remember once we were at a party,
she over drank and she was feeling
nauseous.
It's about to Alice,
shoving my fingers down her throat and
she couldn't have a gag reflex.
Maybe.
I don't think she does know.
But you've never ever done it with booze
and it came up in voluntarily?
No,
I like,
I blacked out a few times from alcohol,
but I would still not dangerous.
But regardless,
it's serving you well.
And because,
uh,
I got to say it,
there was this funny moment where before
we knew she was pregnant and she was
like,
God,
this,
this pizza's so good.
Started eating food,
enjoying food,
or we're like,
what the hell is going on here?
And then like a couple days later I
found out she was pregnant.
That's when I tell you,
after I gave birth to our second son,
food just tasted like cardboard.
Like I lost.
That's what I'm afraid of because when
you're,
when you're pregnant it's like you're
hot and you just can't.
I couldn't stop eating.
I'm like enjoying food for the first
time in a long time.
I don't know,
like,
I don't want it to sound depressing,
but I'm enjoying food click rate.
Yeah.
I guess like when you're high and what
are you eating the most of?
What do you crave?
I was just telling you I don't crave
meat,
right?
I don't.
I can't normally like Meta or.
No,
no,
but I'm like this is more than usual.
More kind of aversion because usually
it's the opposite.
Women get aversion to like salads when
you're hot trimester because parents,
because your show,
there's no note.
They're going to be the cutest little
parents.
You're going to be the band or the
sweetest fucking bitch.
I swear to God like I've been having
like a midlife crisis and you guys walk
away from that edge.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and you guys are all so supportive in
the sweetest God damn people.
I love just being around you guys.
I've been excited about this podcast
because you guys are so sweet and
calming and like you've got,
you've got like you've got your shit
together and you're so nice and you like
us.
It seems like what we're talking about.
We've been trying to schedule more
dinners and yeah,
it's fun.
I was sick the last time.
I'm still coughing.
I regretted I was a great regret.
No,
no.
I think actually when,
when you got.
I think I was getting sick too.
Yeah,
I got sick also.
I got,
I got antibiotics and it was a whole
thing.
I didn't go there.
Are you going to do a natural birth at
the house?
Are you going to rent like a tub at the
house?
The house live of the podcast.
Oh,
you don't know this?
Uh,
Jews aren't more on wait.
Is that a Catholic Christian fucking
Weirdos out there who were absolutely.
Wait,
why the Christian thing?
It's a happy thing.
It's weird.
Why?
Tell me what you're talking about.
So there are lunatics.
They're usually white.
They usually white.
It's white people.
It's white hippie Vegan types.
They'll have home births and they'll get
like a tub and put it in the living room
and then give birth in a tub and just
not have any epidural or any pain meds.
You know that your reaction is exactly
what the reaction should be.
Healthy.
React and do people come and walk?
They have parties.
Every party.
Absolutely.
What do you expect that water.
It looks like in the bath,
it's so hot.
I'll take a sip at the end.
I would jump into those papers,
ceremonies that the dad then gets into
Jackson.
He jerks,
right.
It's huge load load for one delivery.
Oh Wow.
That sounds.
Yeah,
I'm into that.
But yeah.
So you know Kat,
Kat von d tattoo artist.
She's like a famous tattoo artist.
Anyway,
she's praying right now and she puts on
instagram and she's going to have a home
birth and no vaccinations.
Vaccinations on the kid and she's been.
So she's eating Vegan through pregnancy
and look,
hey,
that's all more power.
That's your choice.
But she just gets lit up like honestly,
you guys going to vaccinate
or how stupid thing is that?
Um,
when I was born I don't think I had
autism,
but now I'm pretty sure that I do.
So I haven't seen any.
So I think no vaccines,
whatever the vaccine is for to prevent
autism.
You don't want that.
I want.
Oh yeah,
she was,
she's got a lot of views.
She has.
She's very popular,
very popular.
I really liked her actually.
She was on that show,
las forever and Miami ink.
Um,
but she just gets lit up,
you know,
you kind of asked for it when you're
home.
Birth is,
uh,
is this something relevant here,
Dan?
A nut?
She's talking about the home birthing
brought my husband and I closer,
Yada Yada,
Yada.
Sisterhood,
brotherhood.
Naturally I've become more empathetic.
Can you scroll down,
Dan?
Is there any relevant a part here?
Oh yeah.
Because the captions,
pretty bunch of hub bub vaccine kids
idiot vaccine.
Your kids idiot.
Yeah.
Well,
I do think that [inaudible] is pretty
insane.
I mean,
it's so insane.
What are,
who are these people?
Where are they,
where are these people?
There's a lot of conspiracy theory.
I mean that a lot of people,
like they'll realize that,
you know,
the American medical journals have
debunked that entertained for a while
and then I actually did a valid study on
it and yeah.
You know,
why are we not all walking around with
autism?
Why are we all not great?
I mean,
we're all,
we're all vaccinated and smallpox has
gone,
but I mean,
well I guess we are a little autistic.
I mean,
look,
look at what's going on here.
I think I might have something to do
with new jacket every day.
Every day.
Really.
Are you going to leave clues relate to
find what's the little nut trail now?
The detective's gonna catch you man.
Sometimes I wish I jerked off less,
but I can't just know.
Part of your thing,
it's just your daily downside.
Do I do have concern that it is a
compulsive behavior?
That might be true.
Let me ask you this because there was a
comic who I won't sell out,
but a comic told me that we were going
to do a show and he was like,
yeah,
you know,
I,
I jerk off like in the hotel before
shows and I was like,
oh my God,
I would not do that at all because it
would make me too tired.
I was like,
I don't want to feel tired to go do the
show.
The opposite.
I would like to.
I would do it after a show,
like get back to the room and easy and
then Romance,
oh,
I like to spend time with me.
No,
but does it not?
Can you do it?
And then like,
are you the type that it kind of knocks
you out or you're like,
oh,
I can just go out.
It depends,
you know,
I found that jerking off in the morning
is generally a bad idea really,
because it'll,
it could slow your day down so much
because once you jerk off,
like you're going to be on your phone,
if you had like a big event,
like I don't know you,
you had to.
No,
no,
no.
I won't do it right before.
No Way.
Yeah,
that's what I was.
No Way skype performs jerker generally.
I'm a night jack.
He was keeping notes.
Aren't you guys together?
I assume you're watching your shows at
night.
You're married.
I guess I fall asleep first book.
There's not.
Look,
it happens you.
This is something that just happens.
And,
and uh,
you know,
my clothes were.
When are you sneaking off?
Are you of these guys to do?
You pull up the Samsung and this turned
into an acquisition.
Yeah,
I generally,
yes.
The phone.
Yeah.
I'll use the phone.
Do you ever do that thing?
I've done this where like you kind of
pay attention to how deeply she's
sleeping and you're like,
I think I can do it right here.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
You are so sick and then you have
masturbated in the bed when Tom was
sleeping.
No.
Have you don't think so.
You have.
Yeah.
There's no shame.
No,
I get so embarrassed.
Look at me.
I'm fucked.
I'm telling everybody about my
compulsive masturbating jerking off one
time in the bed when you guys are,
you're not afraid of being caught.
I think the fear of being caught so
thrill though,
right?
Not For me.
I don't like being afraid.
No.
I'm not afraid of being caught in that.
I'm so confident that I'm not going to
be caught here,
like asking for me to find I know what
I'm doing.
She doesn't want to catch me know too
because I noticed that like I,
you know,
my morning shower is not usually.
Not usually not.
Sometimes I do,
but you always go like,
is it cool to come in,
you know,
what the fuck you're doing in there,
and I've a couple of times I've been
choking my chicken and you came in but
you were like a wreck.
Yeah.
But I was able to position myself kind
of like hey baby was also enough steam,
you know,
so I was like,
what's the thing?
We moved to a new house recently and the
bathroom,
I don't have any privacy there because
it's connected with the bedroom and so
I'm really afraid to go for the shower
these days because if you walk in it's
going to be so obvious that I'm like
concealing my toner.
You guys have a new game though.
This can be a fun game.
You'll continually jerk off every day.
You know what altered off and you could
be watching tv if that's cool with you.
It's not gonna Bother.
No,
I don't think we're a little strange.
Like if you're watching like a 90 day
fiance and I'm just beating off.
Is that a problem?
While we were watching?
No,
that would be weird.
Yeah.
You can't just get up and kitting,
like taking a dump.
You can't just get up and take it down.
90 Day fiance you watched that?
We started to.
And then we forgot about it.
Dude.
What's the.
Okay,
what is the,
uh,
the video you parody?
Like what'd you make fun of the
reaction?
Yeah.
So you're talking about our new video.
Yeah,
I loved it.
It was a plc pilot for ICAT.
Fished my kid.
That's so weird.
Which is funny because.
And they roasted the day especially for
being such a fucking Weirdo.
This is such a great show.
It never got picked up.
It's funny because he of all people drew
the line somehow.
Speaker roster is nothing but like obese
people,
small people.
John even had one that like,
I'm a fat black dwarf.
They follow people that have
nothing inherently interesting about
them.
Other than that they look unusual.
Yeah.
Like I love it.
I could watch that channel was nonstop
do them.
When I'm bored I go straight to TLC and
I'll tell you I got sucked in.
I was watching this one about my 600 lb.
Life been there.
Yeah.
And actually it surprised me because
there was actually a lot of,
uh,
I'll tell you what,
it shocked me because I was expecting
something really superficial,
but they followed this lady for like 10
years.
It was pretty crazy.
I mean,
it was,
she'd make it out.
All right.
Unbelievable.
She passed away.
Really?
She didn't.
Oh,
I don't know why I made that joke.
I think it's because he was pregnant.
It's like a dad joke.
Oh,
you were becoming a dad.
I'll make a joke.
Like,
why
that's a joke,
but it's like,
why did I just lie?
Did I tell you about my,
a Cheddar cheese addiction?
No,
it's pretty mild.
Um,
no haters.
What's up now?
That was a terrible.
I'm a fucking experience,
dad.
We talking about that.
You've been around the block.
You're setting him up so excited for you
to,
to be parents.
Do you want to say Isla?
Since she's been pregnant,
she's like,
she's like radiant.
She's beautiful.
She's looking good.
She's eating her stuff.
It's incredible.
I find it.
I'm,
I'm amazed by it.
I truly think it's amazing.
And I'm also simultaneously so thankful
that I don't have to give birth.
And I mean genuinely.
And I'm so appreciative.
You've said about how you.
There's no way for you to not be kind of
resentful.
Oh yeah.
Don't you hate his guts,
but you're doing all the work.
Like I've,
I'm,
I'm not even there yet,
but I'm already going to get like,
there's no way that those levels that
are coming to.
Oh yeah.
Well here's the.
Here's the neat part.
Okay,
you're right,
right now you're doing all the work.
Nine months,
you're going to be enormous.
You're going to gain weight,
you're feet are going to grow,
your vision is going to get worse.
It's going to be destroyed.
Oh,
I look it.
I'm wearing glasses.
Now your vision gets worse.
Pregnancy,
of course,
pressure can lift that fluid in your
eyes.
Does it get better when you worse?
So now doctor is working here.
This is going to be wrecked,
right?
And you're going to hate this fox.
You're a hater,
and then you're having meeting.
They're going to hate Tom.
That'd be great for me.
Here's what happens.
Here's what happens in two years time
when that little boy or girl is running
around and hyperactive and everything
and you see her two year old kicked out
and the nuts.
It's all.
Yeah,
because now he's getting it because now
it's Daddy,
Daddy,
daddy and play Horsey,
Horsey Horsey and you get all that
stuff.
So then it's awesome.
Before my reckoning comes.
That's right.
He'll kick in.
Then daddy will kick in later.
But he's a good one though.
There's like shit.
You can tell that.
Well that remains to be seen,
but I am excited.
Are you guys going to be Craig?
Excited?
What's your biggest fear but given
birth.
Oh,
easy.
Just take drugs.
Drugs.
That's what I'm saying.
A lot of.
I was trying to talk.
I'm like,
Eh,
if it takes an extra couple hours and
you don't feel pain.
The rest of my grades,
drugs,
drugs to contractions on this last one.
And I was like,
let's go drug drug drugs.
And I didn't feel like not only do they
get,
is it like mind altering drugs?
It's like an opioid,
right?
Oh No,
they put it in your spinal column so it
doesn't affect the child.
You just don't feel it or anything.
No chill because you're like,
I'm not in pain and anguish and really
not feel the pain of not a fucking man.
That's amazing.
She's a,
she's so scared of pain that,
that like in the months leading up to
the delivery who would do checkups,
you don't need to do more and more
checkups and then as you get close to
they become weekly checkups and she
would go like,
and what is the deal when,
when I get to the document,
I know she'll be like,
and when does the pain meds come?
And he's like,
whenever you want,
that's right,
and you're gonna fucking make sure the
anesthesiologist is there.
And He'd be like,
yes.
And then it became a routine.
Like she blocked it.
He's like,
it'll be all set up.
We're adding smart.
Yeah.
And I think you're a great because you
should take a note.
I agree.
Ask Your doctor because a lot of bitches
out there,
I don't know,
some warrior bitches that want to be
like,
well,
yeah,
if you're not already had the idea.
I know that it wasn't dead.
Well,
I'll tell you what.
You're really embracing it.
I've gotten so terrible,
so I had the flu and I've coughed so
much I can cough anymore.
We always hang out because I sit next to
him.
I know coffee like my ear last night it
goes,
you're hurting my ear.
And I'm like,
I'm suffering.
What about so I cannot muster cough
anymore.
Like my body literally cannot because
you thought you were really sick.
Go to the doctor.
So it's one of these you can't cough,
but you've got to get the mucus out.
So disgusting.
Right?
So what were you saying?
So I'm saying you got to ask your doc
when they're going to give you the meds
because there are some doctors that are
evil and won't give a woman the epidural
until she's so much dilated or whatever.
They want you to be further along before
because it can stop contractions and
slow it down and keep it going.
They want to make sure you're
progressing enough before they give you
pain meds because it can slow everything
down.
Just make sure you get someone to
pregnancies last.
Oh,
I don't know.
I don't know what.
I didn't know how to say that.
No,
no.
You know what you mean,
like eight,
17,
18 hours top to bottom.
That's not 17.
18 actively.
No,
no,
no.
Take of the hospital.
Yeah.
So first for my son came on his due date
and like literally I had contractions at
two in the morning.
We were at the hospital by what?
Four?
Five in the morning and then.
But then there's like,
you know,
there's long periods and dilate.
It takes hours to dilate.
They consider that you're in labor,
so your body active,
pushing,
opening.
Literally your cervix is dilating.
Has to get to 10 so that the head can
come out crazy.
It's active labor for you as an hour and
change on the second one.
So then you go into where it's go time
and if the baby's going about to come
and then you can end.
By the way,
there's doctors that won't turn your
epidural down so that you don't feel
pain during the pushing.
Make sure to ask this guy.
A lot of them will be like glued
epidural wore off.
No I didn't.
They can keep that drip going and they
tell you to push,
you push,
push,
push and then bang.
I mean if you're lucky,
you know,
I had my tank cut twice,
but other than that I didn't feel it
though.
You don't feel shit.
Your ass hole one hole.
Yeah.
You know what?
When that kid grows up and they're old
enough to understand,
we need to be like,
listen,
if they're misbehaving,
listen you little shit in your mom's
asshole.
I'll make them care.
I'll take picture.
I remember the first one.
Fuck you mom.
Doctor was Regina.
The doctor was like,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
I got a check here.
Make sure can you know.
She goes,
do you mind if I put my finger in your
anus to make sure there's two holes?
I was like,
um,
I'd mind if you didn't.
She was selling and she goes,
do you mind if I put my finger in your
fucking leg in there?
I don't feel anything.
I don't care.
I'll take a picture.
That's an a,
maybe a crazy thing,
but make it like super close so no one
can tell what it is that in the bay.
The kids every fucking time I do,
I think they're supposed to be two holes
right there.
Yeah.
So are you feeling super resentful
already of your body?
And I'm more like I'm knowing.
I know that it's coming.
Those feelings that I get,
I get little tastes of resentment.
I think little shadows of resentment now
it comes out a little subtle ways.
Like a we're just hanging in bed and
then she just looks at me like you fuck.
And I'm like,
oh,
are you alright?
And she's like,
no,
everything's fine.
You know,
I already can't fit in my clothes that
she can see the wave way out there that
go slowly.
But I think see he's going to be good
because he adores and you can tell
there's a lot of guys that aren't like
he adored,
so you're going to feel the resentment,
but you're going to be able to navigate.
I feel like somehow that makes her angry
some of the times when I'm like,
you're amazing.
I can't believe you're having this baby.
It's a credit line.
She's like,
she's like,
fuck you.
They're like that sometimes you can't
stop.
There were times too where I'm like,
I just don't know what's going on.
I to know what to say.
And then you figure out like that.
There's nothing I can say.
You just got to shut the fuck up yet.
That's something you learned in marriage
with them?
Yeah,
because it's like I said everything
right.
I did everything right.
And,
and what,
uh,
what can I tell you?
And Isla is just like,
just leave,
just leave me alone.
Just wake up and I'm bad moon.
So they'll have this thing where
sometimes I just wake up on the wrong
side of the bed.
That's what they call it.
But when you get mad or irritated,
I can't,
I always feel like you're mad at me
because when I,
when I get up to that same issue,
you know,
upset,
but you don't know,
you don't think that I'm upset at him
and I'm like,
I'm not.
I think because I think we just.
And we experienced that feeling
differently because when I'm upset I,
I treat you like my ally intentionally
because I don't want you to feel that
I'm mad at you.
But that's just,
that's very interesting.
That's just,
um,
psychologically that's fast.
But I know you're not mad at me.
So.
Yeah.
But I,
I,
I see,
I do the same thing.
What do you do?
So I understand what you're saying when
you're upset.
I was upset at.
I'm like,
Oh man,
she's upset.
I should stay away.
I think she might might be upset at me.
I don't know if you're upset,
you're upset.
But then what I'll do is I think it's
good to leave you alone because I went
in [inaudible] case.
She doesn't want to fucking see me and I
know that now because I'm like,
Isla,
what's wrong?
And he doesn't want to fucking see me.
I'm like,
all right.
That's how she,
it's like,
I just need my coffee.
It's just something like that.
She and I and like the commission is
dirty and I got to clean it and like I
just woke up.
It's something like that,
like I just don't even want to say.
But you want to be asked.
Yeah.
See,
the thing is,
that's what I've learned.
It's a counterintuitive with us.
She actually doesn't want to fucking see
me.
But anyway.
No,
I understand.
But some people process stuff
differently so she might need that time
to do her coffee and get collect
herself.
And maybe you're more of an introvert
with that stuff.
I think I'm like that when I'm upset.
Oh,
you're the worst.
You're avoidant or you don't want to get
in your mind a little bit.
Then understand this emotion because I
don't understand what the Ila kind of.
Because I don't feel that way.
So you're upset at not Christina.
Obviously something completely
different.
And
so you're just in a bad mood and then
somehow that negative energy is just
direct.
Did to whatever is in front of you?
Yeah.
Because he'll get mad at like,
why are there stains on the couch?
And then I'll be like,
oh fuck.
But it's,
I feel like that's directed towards me.
Definitely not.
I know,
but I know that rationally it agitates
me.
Ah Fuck.
He's mad about reverse.
I think we're totally reversed.
But then you'll also do [inaudible] you
know,
too much psychology.
I'd be like fucking stains on the couch
and you'll be like,
oh,
what are you?
Will?
She'll be like,
what?
Are you really mad?
I'm like,
these goddamn stain.
And then she was like,
let's talk.
And like the stains are not going away.
I don't know.
See.
But where I'm real direct,
I'm like,
we have two dogs.
One's a shelter dog,
ones a pure bred.
The shelter dog can live without the
other one.
The purebred is a lovey machine.
I always say,
I'm like that pure bred lovey machine.
Bitsy,
I love you.
What are you doing?
Let's kind.
That's all I want to touch you.
I want to touch you,
and then you're like,
FIFA.
We were like,
I don't know.
Whenever I'm doing my thing.
So when I'm upset though,
I'm saying I like to have you there next
to me to have the.
Let's continue this.
That.
Let's go to a break.
We're over.
We're going to continue this
conversation.
Well,
we are just at the tip of the iceberg
here.
We're psychologically breaking it down.
Guys.
Do not go away.
We will be right back.
Quip.
All right.
What do I need to say about this
beautiful,
magical,
mythical toothbrush that is changing the
game of dental hygiene?
One of the most important things we can
do for our health everyday is brushing
our teeth.
Yet most of us aren't doing it properly
and you're walking around like you just
had a Turd.
Sandwich quip is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers to make brushing your teeth
more simple,
affordable,
and dare I say this Isla Fun and
enjoyable.
Yeah,
it's that good.
Uh,
this okay.
Here.
Let me tell you about,
first of all,
I have sensitive gums as most of us do,
and gums,
they do not heal back.
You need to find soft,
correct bristles that are not going to
corrode your gums because it's not
coming back,
right?
That's what this is.
It's soft,
it's rubbery.
It's the best head I've ever found and
no offense.
Isla is get enough on your sensitive
guns.
People brush too hard at some electric
toothbrushes are way too abrasive.
It's got a built in timer.
That's what this is,
and every 30 seconds it reminds you to
switch sides,
helping guide a fall and even claim up
to 90 percent of us.
Don't brush for two full minutes and
don't even clean evenly.
That's what helps you achieve.
All right,
so that's why I love quip.
That's why I don't use any other
toothbrush.
I love quip and that's why it's backed
by 20,000
dental professionals.
That's a lot of dentists.
Quip starts at just $25.
Guys go to [inaudible] dot com slash
agency.
Right now you get your first refill back
for for you with a quip electric
toothbrush.
That's your first refill back free at
Gte.
Q U I p.com/eight,
three.
There was a lot of problems online when
you're working or you're at work,
if you work for somebody or your own
boss,
there's so many great softwares out
there to help you fix the problems you
have and you don't even know they're out
there.
Well,
Capterra,
that's why they're here to help you find
the exact perfect software for the
perfect fix to the problem that is going
to make your life a thousand times
easier.
You can download their big book,
a free software for free at
Capterra.com/age
three.
They are a free resource to help you
find that perfect beautiful software.
They've got over 300 different software
tools and again,
their big book of free software can help
you find a completely free tool to test
today and it is absolutely free.
It will not cost a penny.
So if you're looking for a new project
management tool,
recruiting software or even email
marketing solutions,
capterra is big book of free software
has got something for you.
So head on over to Capterra.com/hd
today to get that big old book of free
software.
That's Capterra c a,
p e t e r r a.com/
[inaudible] capterra.com/h
three ring is the product that is so
brilliant,
so revolutionary.
It sells itself.
Now let me give you a personal anecdote.
We live in Los Angeles and there's been
a lot of breakins in general and the Los
Angeles area.
And I think that what deters people more
than anything is single rink now have
you see they've got.
It's a,
first of all,
it's a doorbell that has a motion
sensor.
So when somebody approaches the door at,
sends you a mobile notification and it
saves the video and immediately uploads
it to the cloud.
So we've got one at the doorbell and
then we've got security cameras,
floodlights that instantly activate and
blast with light and record the same way
all around the house.
So in a sense,
there's almost no way to approach the
house without us being notified and then
checking the video.
It doesn't matter like even alarm
systems can fail you if you don't have a
shatterproof,
a shatter detector,
they could break it through the window
at leave without even being seen.
Motion detectors,
they'll go off.
Even if your alarm goes off,
the police aren't gonna arrive for
another 30 minutes because they're
trying to call you a bunch of times with
ring,
you see everything that's going on,
but there's no surprises.
And you could call the police
immediately.
Besides that,
somebody stealing packages,
some cuties coming and leaving you a
love note.
You will know who it was.
You know everything that's going around
your house.
This product is changing the world.
I love it.
Now,
as a listener,
you have a special offer on ring starter
kit available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
Cam.
The starter kit has everything you need
to build a ring of security around your
home.
So go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible].
That is ring.com/eight
three.
I'm telling you,
this is a revolutionary product.
I am so happy that we've got it in our
home.
Twenty three and me is a beautiful,
easy to use,
fascinating service that analyzes your
DNA from you,
simply spitting in a little tube,
send it off,
and two weeks later you learn all this
interesting stuff about yourself and
your family.
For example,
you're gonna.
Learn where you're from and that's,
and for me,
this is one of those interesting things
because over the last thousand years
you.
It's so interesting to see where all
these people come from.
It's all there and your spirit was
discover how much neanderthal DNA you
have.
You can also connect with relatives and
find other customers who share your DNA
with other ancestors and this
thanksgiving,
there's no better thing to do than sit
around with your family,
get all the DNA testing and you can
finally blame all your shortcomings and
everything wrong in your life on your
parents and,
and,
and it turns out none of that stuff is
your fault at all,
including food but size.
You can literally brain blame your
parents,
your genetics on food.
Besides,
so there you have it now through
Thanksgiving,
23.
Me Twenty three and me ancestry service
kits are only $49 per kit.
When you buy two or more kits,
that's 50 percent off the regular price
of $99 this holiday,
Lord,
you're 23 and me ancestry service
get@twentythreeandme.com
slash eight three.
That's the numbers 23 and me that slash
h Lee.
Welcome back to the age three broadcasts
they'll ride with us is the wonderful
Thompson [inaudible].
Christina,
pleasure to be here.
Thanks for joining us.
We were talking about all kinds of
things.
Uh,
but you know,
therapy couples therapy.
I did.
Actually.
I did start therapy recent.
No,
I love it.
And it's been nice.
It's been good.
It's only been like five sessions.
But you like it?
Yeah.
You find it beneficial.
Well,
the thing about it is that it's very
much.
I know,
Gosh,
she dad coughed and I got to talk to
them about.
Oh,
eyes.
Everywhere I start thinking about things
that like,
I never thought.
It just puts everything in perspective,
you know?
Um,
this stain is very much not the stain,
you know what I'm saying as you.
But it's been good.
It's been good for me.
Good.
I'm glad.
Thank you.
But yeah,
of course.
I don't know how people don't see
therapists,
honestly.
Like how do you not so helpful?
Will not,
but I do want to go for it.
Especially
having a kid,
I'll tell you that having children is
very healing on,
on one hand and then it dredges up a lot
of other stuff on the Internet.
Yeah,
that's what I'm kind of worried about
too.
I don't want all this damage to figure
it out beforehand.
Yes.
Yeah.
I just don't want to be insane all the
time too,
which affects the kid.
Sure.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
but uh,
but I do,
I know you guys are.
I'm a garth brooks fan.
I love Garth Brooks.
He's such an interesting character.
Is he not Hashtag Hashtag there together
at your Mr.
I can't.
I can.
What is winning first for all of our
viewers?
Let's First Watch garth brooks to give
you all a little taste and then we can
kind of try to get inside his head
because garth Brooks,
I don't understand what's going on.
I can't get a read on this too.
I think it's important because we talk
about it when we talk about him.
It's important for people not in the
note because it's fair that there's
different genres and you don't know who
knows what to recognize how
inconceivably famous.
This guy is good.
It is out of this world.
It's bonkers.
I think,
and I may be wrong,
but last time we were talking about him
on the show,
he's like the number two or maybe the
number one best selling.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Here's the thing.
He outsells the big pop stars of today.
You know,
Bruno Mars,
beyonce,
like he is doing stadiums like we're
fucking football games are played and
they sell out under an hour.
He's a thumb with a cowboy hat.
Yup.
It's other level.
But you know that he was,
I saw a thing of him on Ellen and he,
uh,
he put out like an anthology thing,
like just released one and it was like
this.
And even she goes,
Jesus Christ,
she goes,
this is volume one,
like there's gonna be more.
He's like,
I think so.
most people release these when they're
dead.
That's no fun.
He just puts out raised Christ Jesus
Christ because you fucking hillbilly
slapped him in the face and in his eyes,
you fucking monster.
She doesn't curse.
No,
no,
she didn't say it like Ellen too,
because I find her fascinating.
He goes,
well,
but also super famous.
Let's.
Yeah,
I think it really fucks with you to be
that famous.
I think so too.
But,
but garth,
but here's why we find him fascinating
because I look and no one's disputing
that he's very talented and he's very
successful.
We're not dumping on this guy for that.
But it's that there's something that
doesn't read,
like don't understand the man.
Right.
You know what it is.
It's like if you go,
what's Ethan like,
what's he like?
Which Christina like and you go,
this is kind of their personality,
but with him it feels like a
manufactured personality in the social
media posts.
It always feels like we're saying the
right thing at the right time and it
feels that reads to a lot of people as
inauthentic.
I'm not saying that necessarily is,
but he reads like this can mean if,
if it's just like a four is you're like,
yeah,
is he just euphoric?
And I said,
I don't think so.
I think he's a creep.
I think by the way he's in the videos,
he's just like,
thank God,
thank God for my life.
Like he's just this euphoric guy.
Like maybe that's just who he is.
I think if maybe I want world peace.
I think what happens too is you do these
three hour plus shows to 80 100,000
people screaming and everyone's like,
you're the gray like that many people.
Your your the same bet that he walks
around like,
you know,
like that.
I really liked that.
Well,
for a long texts,
everyone watching less with let's enjoy
some of that recent highlights of the
beautiful and wonderful a national
treasure,
if you will,
or garth brooks.
I regret in my dream for us to love one
another.
All of us,
he leans in because borderline that
almost like if you took the words out
saying that is like,
I'd like to fuck you in the ass hard
tonight.
You know,
it's like a weird sexual tax.
He's saying that his wish for.
What was that?
What was the beginning of world peace?
My wish is for all of us to love each
other,
but it's like for this Christmas a one
of those things.
It's like,
what's your wish?
And he's like,
well,
my wish is for world peace.
First of all,
whenever someone's like,
what's your wish for world peace?
No,
you're not only an abusive.
Yeah.
See,
that's the real question.
What is garth wish?
Garth's wish he doesn't know.
By the way,
I've seen him wear this shirt,
this nike shirt in multiple press
outings,
which makes me also think that he's
like,
it's kind of.
This is what people were Kesha Grand
Knight,
Knight.
Tommy,
I think you've hit on it.
He's pretending pretending to be a
person.
He's actually like a building.
This stadium store he's going to do
right now.
No Shit.
He's going to earn like $400 million.
And the thing is that,
that's crazy.
Country Music is all about.
I'm just an average Joe.
I fucked my cousin,
but that's okay.
The Yankees don't like it,
but we think it's all right.
Yes.
And so that's actually one of.
Not that guy.
It's all about still being.
I'm keeping it real and I'm just,
I'm,
I'm just one of y'all shocks like a
private jet.
But that's the thing is that it's got.
It's all about.
I'm just like,
y'all all this money,
bull shit don't
mean nothing.
And that list.
And I may have a jet stream five.
Yeah.
But oldest money shit don't mean nothing
when you can't fuck your cousin.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right,
let's watch this and have some fun and
let's get fiscal playing music.
Kind of like that.
You hold it too long.
I love this.
Thank you.
God bless you guys.
I love that.
Thank you for this.
Thank you for my life.
God bless you guys.
Instagram.
Hashtag ask.
Garth asked me anything.
Okay.
Hashtag happy.
Hashtag Gore.
Mr Harwood.
Oh,
Hashtag you're in.
What do you mean?
Hey,
if you have to ask yourself,
is making it rain?
Do you think that those four seconds
stares at the end of the videos are
because he's told somebody like,
like when when I'm done I smile at you.
Let that Shit fucking roll.
So they.
No,
no,
be relaxed or do you think he's like,
I think when I'm done talking you'll
know I'm fucking done when I smile and
then just let it roll.
People like when I smile and they're
like,
alright.
And then he finally came too old school.
He's posing for a photo with.
For his aunt.
Yeah,
exactly.
And he just holds it.
Geez.
And also what's disingenuous about the
smile?
Because real smiles,
your face lights up,
it's in the eyes.
The smile is always in the eyes and the
smile doesn't match the eyes.
The chew like a three year old man.
They tell you to smile.
The picture.
Yeah.
Like fucking John Wayne Gacy.
When you look at his face,
I mean he.
He's such a Dang dingus human hot dog.
He's so real.
He's a fucking official dad.
Like he could be on the debt front page
of Dad weekly with a big head stadium.
Was the daughter of your cousin called
the daughter of your cousin?
You have a cousin had a dumb job.
No,
I was setting it up.
I was just trying to set up a country
song where just because my daughter is
my second cousin,
don't dump man.
I love her any less.
I'm going to write some tunes.
They weren't ready to go.
I to remind me of fucking crickets
thing.
That's brutal.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I love that.
I like that.
I really like that.
I want to watch that one again because
we've watched it on this podcast,
but it's such a fucking masterpiece.
That is one of my favorite videos.
Well,
I guess it's official tearing down the
walls.
You know what's happening now is that
this is picking up steam now on twitter
that garth brooks is feed is weird.
Like this
is.
We're starting away.
Have you guys,
you know he's going to.
He's not going to understand.
He's like 20 million phones and he
didn't be like,
well I'm fucking garth brooks.
No,
no,
but it's like 19 million people that
want to see you be weird.
Millennials,
I want to say tim and Eric make a
episode with Garth Brooks.
Like,
all right,
let's ahead.
This humid hot dog.
Yeah,
just the player over radio on radio.
Oh,
is this vic burgers?
Cut.
No.
Queen's birthday.
So I'm taking over all are socialists
Hashtag happy birthday tuition.
Let me ask this question to why on
Trisha's birth birthday
is he taking over?
He asked me how I know.
Well,
why is he taking over Trisha's socials
for her birthday?
It's like,
how is that a president gift?
A gift is that I'm the best and you're
not going to take over.
You could have made a post on your own
self.
Don't be like,
send her some love.
Right?
He's like,
you know what,
I'm not going to shit post on my own
social page.
I'm going to do it on yours.
Right?
Her fans open.
They're like,
oh,
thank God it's garth.
This is awesome.
Hey,
go hashtag.
I'm Mr.
uh,
Mr Today.
That's her last name,
her last name.
So what he's doing is doing this
condescending thing of like,
I'm the mega star.
She's down here,
but I'm,
I'm so humble.
I'm down home today.
Just today,
just today.
Um,
Mr Gear.
But here's the thing,
man.
It's like that.
Um,
I love Mike.
That post is a,
what is that?
That's a perfect husband posts.
Yeah.
All.
He goes,
it's like from the beginning it's like I
love her so much and show her how much
you love her to just put pictures of
cakes Tagore.
And it's like,
so if you watch that,
you're like,
oh,
this guy's just this normal sweet guy.
Just loves his wife is bullshit.
And what does he do for a hobby?
That's what I want to isla thinks.
Isla has this amazing,
authentic and transparent what they
tagged that as I look at the thumbnail
alone,
so let's do this one too.
It was like pay attention to those odd
voice like octave changes.
There's so there's so deliberate and the
choice to do them.
They're deliberate and they don't line
up.
Like why?
Why you would go?
I like,
well like that.
I really liked the thing about reads the
growth,
but the thing about this is that it's so
rehearsed.
It's like,
yes,
it's like a beat for beat.
Like I feel like this is take 100.
Oh yeah.
And he sent it to an assistant and goes,
just finished this gold fucking post
that right now.
Shithead.
And then the guy was,
all right,
put that up.
Garth said to put it up right here.
It was a very telling moment to put it
on when he was reporting to us from
studio g and I know what you're going to
talk to.
And he was doing his spontaneous garth
thing and then the door opened suddenly
and he's like,
is that supposed to happen?
And you can see the rage behind his eyes
and what it is.
It's his birthday and they're surprising
him with a cane.
It's a fraction of a second inside
studio g you see the rage behind his
eyes and make sure out.
I'll be up there for y'all.
I'll be singing my songs.
And then he goes,
is that supposed to happen?
He's like,
happy birthday.
Happy Birthday to Ge.
Refers to himself.
Yeah,
that's on.
That's on a facebook studio.
G posts inside studio g or that one?
Were you in that moment?
Was It on facebook?
I want to see it when he's,
uh,
when he's given you backstage,
he does like a GE alert and he does,
uh,
he,
he's like,
Hey,
look at all these,
uh,
like it was rehearsal sound check.
And he's telling you how,
like everybody,
they come to my shows sometimes they're
like,
look at that guy,
look at that guy.
It's so neat watching everybody else
work.
Like trying to give credits,
fighting guide.
So neat.
Yeah.
And then he goes,
he goes,
hey,
dave turned that down.
Dave.
Turn it down.
And you could see days like,
oh my life's about to say,
but that's the real guy.
Yeah,
Dude.
I bet.
He's like,
I really like.
That is a control.
He's a dictator,
is the way I think he is.
This is the guy whose music never ended
up on Itunes,
get an exclusive deal with Walmart.
That means he's business savvy,
but he's also really in control.
Really calling the shots.
And also let's talk about his alter ego.
Chris Gaines,
this guy is a gold mine.
It's just bizarre.
This gains is one of the weirdest thing
that ever happened to one of the
weirdest things ever happened for people
they don't know.
He got so famous and board being garth
did.
He created an Australian,
I think alter ego's very weird.
Aaron died.
Let me throw up.
But here's the other thing.
Oh,
savagery of this is that Chris was
almost wiped entirely to internet.
Do you know how hard it is to do that
damn near?
It's really very little out there.
He's coming back because people are
talking about Chris Gay dude.
He.
This whole kind of Garth Brooks' name
that's brewing is going to be something
new for him because you cannot fight
against me more.
Fair.
What if it went like this for a while
and then like it built it,
built it pissed him off and then they
were like,
guess what?
Garth Brooks has 10 bodies buried on his
fucking land.
Like He.
That would make sense.
Yeah,
he's makes sense.
Can you talk about that?
When he did Chris Gaines,
a photo shoots,
he would suck his cheeks and because
Chris wasn't supposed to be as big as
Garth,
so that's why I.
So you can see us do.
It was like a vampire.
I think it looks cute as Chris Gaines.
I'm digging Chris Gaines actually,
he's Kinda Gotten Kinda hot.
It's cool.
It is an odd choice though,
right?
To be so it's,
it's essentially like ever never been
anything like that.
Right.
Like the biggest star in music.
But like I'm done.
I'm going to do this realize because I
was reading so much garth stuff that
when he did this,
you know,
no one could talk them out of it.
Right.
Do you think his manager,
I'm talking about this don't do this,
and he was like,
I'm Chris got,
I'm doing it,
and then they're like,
it did poorly,
obviously,
like it wasn't.
It was a disaster,
but still just people knowing that it
was him doing it.
I think I want to say it moved somewhere
close to a million still,
so that's still like,
that's huge.
Yeah.
But he was like,
I'm still 25 million,
I'm sure just what I do.
And then they're like,
oh,
I only sold a million.
He was like,
oh,
that sucks.
But I think it's part of that crazy
insane ego.
Ego's ism where he's like,
I'm going to go make pop music.
Can be an email singer.
Yeah,
that's exceeded that.
It just looked it up.
His Chris Gaines album went double
platinum,
filtered a tremendous failure.
That is how successful that guy's used
to being,
I guess.
Well,
actually I remember reading,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
they had like this huge release and they
bought tons of albums and it was filling
all the music stores and while he did
sell a lot,
there was a little bit.
Overstock.
Overstock for sure.
Sorry.
I know I'm just reeling.
I'm also thinking of rock stars.
I'm sorry.
Actors that became rock stars.
It's like I'm not really successful in
this thing.
Let's fuck that up by trying to
coordinate.
Let's list who we can think of.
Juliet Lewis is doing it right.
She does that.
She's like actually still touring.
Great though.
I think she does.
Bruce Willis.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you got to see that Keanu.
Keanu.
Yes.
The Johnny Depp very actively to the
greatest of all times to golf.
Golf course plays a seller.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is really something.
There was one billy Bob Thorton,
I dunno if you guys recall.
He was very serious about that.
Okay.
There's another one.
He went on a late night show I recall
and they were,
and he was like,
I'm only here to talk about my music.
Eddie Murphy a murder,
and that guy has an amazing voice,
but somehow it was just the corniest
thing ever.
It was awful.
And he was like,
I don't want to.
Even he joined twitter,
I want to say he joined twitter to put
out a music video.
Yeah.
And people were like that.
He was just like,
I'm going about my album now.
I will say the person,
the one person I can think of who it
really worked for was Donald Glover.
Oh,
that's true.
He's childish.
Gambino.
Drake.
Okay.
I thought I was a lesbian before,
but this is like Donald Glover can
actually really do all those things.
You know,
he can.
He's really good at it.
So I think some of the other guys were
talking about like 15 plus years of
being a movie star.
Like you're a household name a thing,
bro.
No.
See you saying,
man,
you wasn't shit.
I want to ask you guys about a story
here.
Sure.
Don't know what to make of it.
It's one of the most bizarre things.
Yeah.
Um,
so let me,
let me start here.
Okay.
There was a teacher who is in a hot
water after getting into a fistfight
with a 14 year old student after the
student berated him,
calling him the n word and throwing a
basketball at him.
Jesus.
So now there's a video.
There's a video of this.
This is what's so crazy to me.
Let let me show you the video first and
then I'll tell you about the aftermath,
which is really what's perplexing to me.
So let's enjoy this a right in our
American school system and they'll skip
forward to where the good stuff happens.
You could tell this kid's a little piece
of shit all day nine and if you're the
one lying bro,
you know you said that shape right here
at home.
You want me to wait first of all this?
It is still.
It is insane that for me that a student
is like,
just like in front of the class saying
that shit.
I don't know what leads to this,
but it's crazy to watch.
Well,
apparently the backstory is that this
teacher was beloved by the school and he
is meant to be very calm.
Nice guy.
Right?
But I guess something just snaps in him
in this moment as you'll see.
But this kids like him,
he's the shit and he's trying to get
under them.
Right.
And I think they have a history together
as well.
These schools are rough though.
Like cuts.
Oh yeah,
he,
he broke them in.
I mean it's obviously not okay at all.
But I think that kid,
he's probably been doing that for a
while.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
It's crazy to see.
He really goes after and feel me just
one that's a grown ass man.
And now here he act like he doesn't
remember what happened.
Oh yeah.
Now he's.
Yeah,
he's panicking.
he's playing.
He's playing a.
He was like,
who hit him?
What happened?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No that was it.
That was mad.
And we missed it.
Just prior to where you started.
It was when he had a basketball.
The kid threw it at him.
Why?
He actually did instigate the physical
aspect of it.
Did I miss?
Maybe it's when it's still vertical
basketball.
So the kid throws the basketball per
teacher.
So.
So here's the part where it gets really
surprising.
Okay.
Well what do I feel bad for everybody?
It's a rough school,
I'm sure.
Like where?
Where is life?
Where it's in La?
It's here in la.
I think that's what I read.
Oh,
Portola.
Junior high.
He's a music teacher of all things.
Yeah.
You went.
I went to,
but I did go to public school or two of
them in La and they're pretty horrible.
Yeah,
the ones I went to anyways,
that's pretty much some shit that
happens.
Yeah,
you can see some really bad homes and
it's hard.
I don't know how to deal with a kid like
that,
you know?
But regardless.
So now,
uh,
opinions are deeply divided.
Yeah.
Um,
and here this is the part that blew me
away.
This guy is a pro.
I mean he's definitely going to be
fired,
right?
Yeah.
He's definitely going to have to think
so.
But then now there's a go fund me for
this guy,
$150,000,
God.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
What does it say here?
This is,
is that him saying,
hey,
this one's real.
I just want you all to know and I'm
letting you know that this go fund me
page is legit.
Yeah,
that's about it.
Where's maywood?
Maywood Academy High School.
Oh,
he was.
He was sent to jail.
He assaulted a child.
Yeah.
Where does it say it?
Said what you have seen the video.
I will not post here.
And sadly he was handcuffed and sent to
jail,
which does make sense.
I mean kind of.
I mean he assaulted as we kick the shit
out of.
You can't really do that.
Like if he threw one punch I,
it'd be like,
oh,
he was threatened.
But then he's beat the shit out of it.
Listen,
I understand kids trigger the shit out
of you,
but you can't hit them.
You know,
he really,
he,
he went after that kid is may and
started beating like La South La,
south La Belle.
It's,
I mean,
I think everyone relates to that
teachers
feeling,
but you just.
I mean if you're the EDC you can't do.
That's what I'm doing.
And so I was like,
wow,
that,
you know,
I feel bad for everybody.
But then when I saw that they had raised
150,000,
that blew me away.
I was like,
who is why it happened to the kid and
the kid can't get in anywhere.
There's no news.
It's just Mr Riley is a.
They did.
They did actually expel the kid.
Yeah.
Well the PR,
they're transferring to a different
school to try and cut down on the drama
basically.
I mean,
look,
the thing is popping off five,
100.
This is three minutes ago.
It really is.
So there you go.
Dude.
I wish.
I wonder if someone would do that for
me.
You know how to really think about that.
Just you can punch me in the phase right
now or vice versa,
whatever.
I wonder if people will be like,
yeah,
we got it.
We got to help out at a step up for Tom.
I've never seen a teacher had a kid.
I've.
No,
it's not.
Well,
one time I had saw a teacher.
CIOCCA kid.
Oh,
that's pretty scary.
Pine.
It was a nice private school I went to.
I was in kindergarten and this kid
wouldn't stop eating roly polies,
you know,
those little bugs.
And um,
I think her name was ms dot darlene
choked him once in a while.
It was wildly throw.
It was a 1980.
Yeah,
that was it.
I've now I'm just remembering this and
she choked him and he turned red.
I remember how she,
that'll teach you not to eat.
Rolling,
you know,
I was having flashbacks now to have.
We had a principal and he wasn't fired
for this and I found it quite traumatic.
There was this girl,
she was just seemed fine,
but she was really anti authority and
this was like in fifth grade and he came
into the class and he whispered
something to her like,
Hey,
I need you to come into that office and
we're all watching.
It was like a whole scene.
And she's like,
no,
I'm not getting up.
And he grabs her arm and he yanks are so
hard.
That desk falls over and he drank and
she drags her by the arm.
What age?
We weren't fifth grade.
So what the fuck dude?
And he wasn't fired for that.
They thought that was all good.
That's different time.
His name was Mr Monday mine,
which makes sense because everybody
fucking hates Monday.
We hated that guy.
I remembered.
I see.
I remember hearing up things.
I never saw a teacher really do
something that crazy,
but I do remember seeing we have trouble
like a troublemaker kid and in high
school and he was fucking off and like
one of the administration people came in
the room and a big guy and the way that
he yelled at this kid who was already a
bad kid,
we were all like,
holy shit man.
I feel like I turned like just.
He goes,
you're never gonna amount to shit.
You're nothing.
And you're like,
nobody lectured them like that.
And it just got really aggressive.
We were all like,
fuck to hear an adult yell at a kid who
is already problematic and be like,
you're not going to amount to shit and
nothing.
And we were like,
it was,
it was way.
It was more brutal than I'm think seeing
somebody get hit just because he just
tore him down.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
the thing is I actually,
now that I'm a little more mature and
having a baby soon,
I understand that kids,
these kids are already kind of like a.
They came up in a bad place that's so
fucked up,
so they are blameless in in a sense that
he likes.
He got it right with this guy too,
so fucked up.
Kid was a piece that you followed him
since and while that was happening,
you're like,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
See if he's right now.
So follow.
This is a piece of shit.
It didn't go well.
It didn't turn out well.
The question is would he be.
If he didn't get that,
maybe he was destined.
He was.
It was going to be.
I was always going to be rough for him
and it ended up
being pretty rough.
So true man.
All those kids.
I grew up with two,
there was one kid that used to flip his
eyelids and right on his arm and
permanent marker and he was like
hyperactive and crazy like he grew up to
be a drug dealer and you can lose her to
kind of know when they're losers.
Kids even I can tell a preschool.
I dropped my kid off,
my God,
my kid's a fucking loser.
You can tell a fucking psycho already.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Problem is they have shitty parents.
That's right.
It's not the kid.
It's a shitty parents.
You got to pay attention to those
parents.
You still,
you.
You'll see it right away.
You'll start to key on it more now,
but when you do like go to a park or
something and you look at the adult and
you're like,
oh,
this motherfucker.
No Way.
When you just started about judge or a
whole new world,
here's the thing,
my mistake,
because I started going to those mommy
and me classes and stuff and I thought,
oh,
it's like this cool sorority,
like we're all in this club of people
that birth other people and all these
women are going to be awesome and it
turns out it's just like a fucking
office.
Like when you work in an office and
you're like 90 percent of these people
suck it really hard and maybe there's
like two cool people you don't want to
can shit out of baby.
That's the thing that I'm starting to
feel with Isla private.
It feels so special and amazing.
It's exciting and I'm already like,
love this kid so much and feels
incredible.
I,
I.
The only thing I can relate it to is our
dog,
which I since we got him has been like
the center of my life.
I love him so much.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
this baby's going to be like way beyond
that.
And it feels like so unique and special
and then you realize that everybody's
got a fucking kid and that's part of the
problem.
But do you realize how many of them.
Do you ever think about how many of them
don't go?
Like,
oh,
this is the fucking most amazing thing.
There's definitely a lot of people like
that who are like,
yeah,
we haven't a kid.
My mom,
I'd say a lot of people are like that
and they just treat it like no big deal.
I think it just really,
I think mean Ila got so lucky in the
timing of it.
We've got everything in the right place.
I could see if I,
if I had a baby when I was 18,
that baby be fucked.
So I think about that a lot.
That baby would be fucked.
Oh yeah.
You think about when you busted in some
chick and you're like,
shit,
if she had had that kid,
I'd be fucked.
Yeah,
it'd be like talking to like my 22 year
old son right now.
And He'd be like,
we're worried.
I'd be like,
I was trying to do shit,
man.
Things are all right now.
Do you want to go to Jamaica?
Let's go.
I'll take you.
I mean you probably would.
You probably wouldn't.
You'd probably be driving a truck or
something.
Yeah,
probably.
I mean I didn't know what your capacity
is.
You would not be living your dream.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But have you had those thoughts though
about like this gang that skank some
other scanning all the chicks that you
would call them and manny with
protection.
Think about dumping all those clips into
those family wagons and you're just
like,
man,
that could have been my baby mama.
How many women as I can we talk about
partners?
How mean it's got to be less than we go
with the horse?
Shit.
Let me tell you,
I won't lie.
You think he lives about how many people
you know?
Here's a firm number.
Well,
let's,
let's crush Tom.
How many paid love you?
Fuck that.
You can ballpark it.
Here's the.
It's not that high.
What it is is this.
This is the truth.
I W I didn't have many relationships.
So there's like.
I'll think of the numbers and I'll be
like,
oh,
it's not that high,
and then as I'm counting,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
there was that beach week where I met
that chick so well.
I couldn't even tell what race she was
like before I became monogamous with
Isla.
I did all this and I have like a from
rough estimate in my head and obviously
that accountant has not given up,
but I'm around 10.
I'm not much more high.
Higher above that.
Why don't you just guess that is where I
know I'm saying changes every five years
when I asked how I'm out there.
I think so.
Yeah,
No,
it is.
It is.
It's like it's.
I think it's like,
I think it's somewhere between 14 and
19.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a big difference.
Well,
I guess you do have some.
There are some weekends in college and
my cognitive thing is there are some you
forget for sure there are.
How are you forgetting who you are?
Jacket,
hooking up with people you're in
relationships with and I didn't want to.
I wanted it to be like,
what's up bitch?
Just take her back.
I get it.
But I already crunched the numbers.
I really thought about it one day and I
was like,
oh yeah,
there was no.
They were all almost all bad by the way.
I feel like random hooking up was always
just so fucking.
It wasn't.
I'm not built for dating.
I'm a monogamous all the way.
I could not survive in today's like
disposable human.
Like swiping left.
We actually,
we can make a loop there.
I think we could probably figure it out.
Jesus.
So done.
I'm sorry.
Um,
I think maybe though.
I think we can.
I think I really do think it's like 15
or something,
but I just haven't really hammered.
It's nothing crazy man.
50 pluses.
We're no,
wait,
what's your number?
We didn't endorse.
It's very small.
Very small.
Like less than five.
No,
that's good.
Oh wait,
how many?
It's a three.
So interesting.
I know me and another one,
but I don't know if it was the third one
is.
Well now you have your own to tyler
problem.
I'm curious,
but it's not a.
we'll talk about it.
We'll talk about it later.
Now I'm pissed actually.
I know about him.
What's your number?
It's under 10.
Which the number you gave me shit about
none.
Same thing for freshman numbers.
Last time I had a new fresh deck.
It's wet now for 14.
Rusty and ashy.
I will say this.
I will give you credit for this.
You know their names.
I know their names.
I know who they are.
I would say 85 percent.
I don't know their name.
That's weird.
I know.
80 five percent.
I wouldn't know their name.
Know because I find is like a short
Asian fault.
Like I know that stuff about them but I
don't know anything else are crazy.
But looking back I think a lot of like
the one night stands I had was just like
a,
you know what it is,
is that I was always looking for
monogamy but it was always just almost
like a confidence thing.
I'm secure and you just want to be like,
feel desirable.
This is why we are fucking one.
I'm exactly the same.
I'm serious.
Yeah,
I'm exactly the same.
I was the same way,
I was looking for a relationship and
lack the confidence to insecure and then
I would just,
you know,
do that and then half the time I swear
to you,
I was,
you'd think I was the guy that was like
hooking up later.
I was like,
what are you doing later?
And then the girl would be like,
Ugh,
like going home,
like I don't want to hang out with.
You played it real cool with me.
Then what do you mean you weren't,
you weren't like that with me.
What are you talking about?
I was the one that was like,
c'mon,
let's do it.
Yeah,
because you were like a total slu tea,
but I was not really,
that's not what that means.
I it,
I said no,
she was a triple dsl.
But when I met her and then I was like,
you were,
you were like,
let's smash.
Come on.
Stop being a bitch.
That as she dick,
he was supposed to be my first one night
stand because I was just out of
relationship of four years and I said,
I'm going to finally do this.
Everyone else has been doing.
Yeah,
I'm going to just fuck a person that I
think is cute and just move on with it.
So he was supposed to be a one night
stand and I just liked him too much.
That's great.
Grateful poet.
Bounce.
I threw some really good day.
Then I was really.
I was really giving it to you.
It was performing.
Where are you really?
And you concur.
You were like,
oh,
that was a good one.
I liked him so much.
He was great in bed and he was great.
Here's the thing.
I was 25.
Yeah.
I was really there for longer.
I think he's even cuter.
I think you're cuter now more than ever.
You don't ever say I'm cute.
I don't hear as smashing the Isa.
Isa.
You're the cutest.
That's more dead.
Come on.
Tell them I say that.
How cute do you think it's okay though?
I,
I'm secured enough.
Now.
I do require a little coddling.
I do want a little affirmation.
Uh,
you know,
but I'm okay.
I require a lie.
I would like a lot.
I can see you and I are similar that
way.
Where I,
I liked the praise.
I like the peds,
I want it all,
but I get by on what I know that person,
but I,
I lay it on you,
right?
I give it to you.
Right?
And you like it.
Let's do this.
This really interesting because you give
what you like.
I love your kid.
I mean what I say and I want you to feel
good and happy,
but uh,
I want to hear that.
I'm cute.
Okay.
Can we?
Maybe.
So now we're waiting.
So how,
how do I look?
How do you show them that you love?
What's your coffee in the morning?
I'm defending.
She wants me to coffee and that's very
sweet always.
But sometimes I go downstairs,
I make it and I'm bringing it up.
First of all,
I want to clarify that you're not doing
this everyday.
Isla isn't going down to cooking
breakfast and like taking care of
sometimes and sometimes it's me by the
way.
I just want to make this picture clear.
Sometimes he'll surprise me with coffee
in the morning.
I think that's very sweet.
I appreciate that.
I remember when she used to do that.
She didn't say it was good before we had
the second baby.
I was bringing you coffee,
but then I got to run down to that
second baby.
I think you look Super Fox.
Who was like my glasses,
my mom eyes.
I like it a lot.
This is great.
I do.
This is like the Valentine's Day
episodes,
but I have to say Tom's been doing.
He will make marital love and then he'll
be like,
I didn't fart that whole time.
You usually drink sex?
No,
I never do,
but I'm saying sometimes I look for a
little bit of approval for doing that.
Like I'll be like,
do you realize that I had to Fart the
whole time and I didn't know.
No,
not
right away,
but a few minutes later.
Oh yeah.
I feel like I would fart what I feel
like I would because I have a personal.
It's a principle that I will never hold
a car.
I will never hold a fart.
Yeah,
but you said you like you didn't even
know I was starting there and no,
I haven't noticed too far.
Well,
I don't remember specific times,
but I don't.
I on principle do not hold farson.
I think it's a good move to hold them in
probably during sex.
So you think you would just let it go?
Yeah,
really think she'd be like,
hey man,
maybe let's take a break.
Well,
so far pay.
No,
not even a sex break for a second.
And she'd be like,
let's air this thing out.
Let's pick this up next week.
Yeah,
go back to your jerking once a day.
I know it is.
Yeah.
I don't know if I.
I'm just saying that I.
I generally am not.
I'm against holding cards.
I choose my principle in life.
One of my guiding principles,
timelines it when I buy him stuff.
You like presence,
right?
He's right though because what else do I
do a lot?
I give you presence.
You liked what?
You get a gift giver.
I love giving gifts.
Really?
Yeah.
I always,
I've always been a gift giving and I
guess that is true.
It's like you're kind of saying like,
hey,
why don't you give me something new,
what you do,
what you will,
but that is a good relationship tip for
everyone watching.
If you're with your significant other,
see what they do for you when they're
being nice.
That's what they want.
Yeah.
You want me to bring a coffee?
Right?
I want you to bring me coffee to.
All right.
No worries.
That's all you.
But I have to say,
I do love being monogamous.
I love and I can share this sentiment
with you guys because you guys are the
greatest.
But um,
I love so much.
Being in a good monogamous relationship
is the best.
It's amazing.
I wouldn't,
I don't know how to funk.
I mean,
I was obviously single before that and I
don't think it was for me,
you know,
I really don't.
I think um,
but I feel much more grounded and normal
and everything in a committed
relationship literally.
And even more so with babies and stuff.
I was going to say that actually it
wasn't until we had children.
I think that you really,
you,
I just see you really happy now.
Like Alice,
our son is almost three years old and
you know,
they play together.
It's the cutest thing ever.
It's really nice.
It's really fun.
Yeah.
I mean,
what is dance has stopped futzing with
your mic.
It keeps going.
Hi.
What do you.
All of a sudden my grandma bought some,
but um,
yeah,
it's the best.
Monogamy is the best thing.
I remembered the cricket.
Cricket,
right.
Let's
let people know.
So a cricket obviously is,
it's cold as Jesus.
It's so fucking mean to drop.
I mean,
you know,
it's funny among friends but I'm saying
in real life to do,
to do quick,
they'll do that.
Like on,
on radio,
somebody bombs,
you know,
like that's,
that's like that's me reeling in that
moment that,
that feel bad.
Oh yeah.
It feels bad,
right?
The universal.
Your bombing.
Yeah.
So I was working at a comedy club and to
be like real clear,
like the comics are obviously separate
from all staff.
Like there's no such thing really as
staff unless there's a long history
getting in on the joking right.
And there was this guy and he wasn't
very good and he was trying to stand up
definitely later than he should have
been trying,
but he started at like,
I know he,
he started at like in like he was a
corporate guy,
let me talk in like a suit,
you know,
and he's,
he's all of a sudden gets this thing I
want to do,
stand up and he works out a deal where
like these clubs,
he would do provide some service like on
the business side and then they would
let him host shows.
It was a bad deal for both.
So that's almost a betrayal to him
because you cut,
earned that.
Exactly.
Doom.
That was really weird.
He was taking spots from like working
comics.
It was weird.
So I do a weekend where he is hosting
the show and he's,
I mean you look,
he's not the worst but he's just not.
It's not good and you can tell it's
probably isn't going to pan out and the
the Dj,
the sound guy from the Dj booth during
this guy set in front of a packed house,
the guy would hit a joke and the Dj
would play crickets and I was,
oh my God,
my brain loaded.
I was like,
what are you doing?
Because it was so cruel and like,
but also like kind of ballsy like the
guy in a weird way.
It didn't deserve that he deserved being
fucked with.
But like the whole thing is burned into
my memory because I also felt for him
onstage.
I'm like,
you can't do that to him,
but that's how much.
He was like,
Oh fuck you man.
he snapped back and I was like,
I remember I was sitting in the
bathroom.
I'm like,
I've never seen that.
I've never seen the fence.
I've never seen the guy be like,
fuck this comment.
Wow,
hit hit the crickets.
Well,
welcome to the podcast,
but he goes,
crooked car smashes me with that at
least several times,
but I liked that between you guys.
So that I can do it too,
like I guess that would be insane if we
didn't tell you guys are,
well we're,
we're friendly.
But like say it's just some random
person.
You're like,
you're just like,
yeah.
And then we,
I should test that out.
It's a quick.
You could,
you could really
go wrong sensibility with that person.
It could be like,
you know what,
this was nice meeting you guys.
Absolutely.
Walk out.
You guys as comics.
Definitely have an aversion to the
crickets though.
Yeah man.
For sure.
I feel better if that wasn't an option.
Yeah,
take that off.
If you've taken a shit today or not.
I just do it.
I know I've had to shit for a couple of
hours but I can always sitting on it.
So it helped find that shitting.
That should be your twitter.
So let me tell you guys some.
I have some new shitting updates of all
of our,
of our.
So I was taking metamucil,
which is a,
as you know,
you know what metamucil?
Yes.
Yep.
And so I ran into the metamucil and I
started taking costco a generic why?
Because it was there.
What does it matter?
Well,
hold on your conclusions because since I
started taking these generics,
super turned on right now.
You are cute.
I talked to you about shit or the common
ground.
What happened with this generic?
Amazing,
amazing,
perfect little nuggets.
I'm talking like strong.
When do you take what time of day?
Usually I'll take two with every meal.
Every meal.
Where you're supposed to take like 20 in
a day.
You know why it says take five five
times a day.
I swear to you.
I agree.
It's insane.
Amount of horse.
I'm just a guy trying to have some clean
shifts.
What about Coca Cola Cola?
That sounds.
I think it was colon.
No,
it's a stool softener.
You take it after you give birth to
start the engine again.
Oh,
I mean that's not you.
You're taking too many capsules a day.
That's a lot of fiber.
All my shit's.
Look fucking fantastic.
Photos of them.
How's the wiping when I should like
that?
It's like an hour.
Did you get a lead?
You have a good washlet?
No,
not yet.
Gotten to that yet,
but I do want to.
I want to total it up.
It's on our list.
We were doing like a gate and yeah,
we've got a lot of blind not to see.
I got to get some privacy,
man.
I know I need.
I do,
but I am actually curious when you have
the baby,
tell me what I have is you have the baby
and then you take the baby home and then
you're just at home with the baby.
Like baby number two,
baby number two.
So this both times we've lived pretty
close to the hospital.
You not more than a 10 minute drive.
Really 12 on the drive home.
This time I pulled over just to double
check because I was like,
all right.
He was strangled by the seatbelt was so
small in that car,
driving from that
with Baden and I'm like,
so wait,
I'm starting to panic.
Gosh,
yeah,
yeah.
They're like this.
That's the case.
You have an accident or anything?
Oh yeah.
You pack them in there and at the first
kid,
the first kid we didn't even know how to
buckle a kid into the car.
We to ask the nurse to come out and help
us in the hospital.
I'm like,
hi.
You know,
like can you take that baby home and
you're sleep deprived already because
you've been giving.
You gave birth 24,
48 hours before and now you've got this
being.
And we did shifts.
It's so terrifying.
I remember we were watching a star wars
movie.
Yeah.
And we,
uh,
it was like six days later and we were
15 minutes into the movie,
we would walk.
Then you'd think I'm gonna wash it and
you've watched like a minute you're
like,
oh my God,
you just.
And then you'd wake up because the baby
woke up and then,
you know,
it'd be like 3:30
and she'd be like,
go to bed.
I'd go to bed and she'd be on the
ground.
Were you guys just like off during that
time?
It was kind of great because it was
December.
Yeah,
near December 14th.
I came to Ellis.
So it was right before the holidays.
So it was.
It was your birthday you though.
It was a nice number.
Twelve is mine,
but cool.
Yeah,
but you're going to have a summer baby,
which is kind of even better because
you're not in the cold and flu season.
They read you the don't take the baby
end of the mall.
It's gonna catch this airborne diseases
and that's nice because in the summer
the days are longer so it's.
That's true.
It's going to be easier for you guys.
We're going to take like two weeks off
for sure.
I think it will take longer.
I just hope so.
No,
no.
I'm just going to come in and do the
podcast or something.
I don't know.
Is that enough?
You take as much time as you want.
I'm for you.
I'm wondering.
Well,
I'm gonna run in and I think it'd be fun
to talk to everybody about what's going
on.
It's not a big commitment.
Got some.
I got some ideas for you,
but I'm so I'm very excited to spending
like just that family time.
It's great.
You'll never get that again.
You know,
especially first baby,
is that the scariest moment?
Like when did that first baby you just
bring it home.
You're like,
I'm terrified of that.
Like,
seriously.
Well here's what you can do to help.
If you have a mom who you want to have
around you.
Some people don't,
I didn't it.
So if you don't have a parent or some
maternal figure that can walk you
through it,
hire someone if you can afford it.
If you can't afford it,
hire someone.
Hire a Doula.
Somebody who can help you through your
pregnancy and delivery and bu there just
to take care of you and that baby and
your family.
Because we were lucky we had a girl come
and cook for us a little and help us
out,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
it's kind of,
you need them all.
We didn't have any family.
I mean my mom plants too.
Visit.
But you know,
for a couple of weeks when would you
give birth?
And my mom lives here.
Yeah,
there is that,
that thing is like the first 90 days.
That's,
that's best.
The Harris,
you know,
they,
yeah.
That's what you want to get through it.
Just know that after the first 90 days
it gets a lot easier and they turn into
babies and you start to see personality
you have.
And you were telling me about the car
ride home.
You didn't finish that.
Did you know just
that?
I was,
I started.
I was like,
is he all right?
And she was like,
yeah,
he's fine.
I was like,
I dunno.
And she was like,
do you want to pull over?
I go,
yeah,
I want to pull over,
pull over.
So I pulled over and I just,
I mean it was like one of those like ocd
kind of things where you're like,
did I,
did I lock the door?
And I locked the door.
Like it was like that.
I just,
you know,
I was like,
yeah,
he's all right.
I just had to double check even though,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
Pull over real quick.
Yeah,
sure.
That's a thing.
So you spend the night in the hospital
for a day or two.
So it depends on the delivery.
Do you have an easy peasy,
you know,
whatever delivery,
delivery,
delivery it comes out if a blaster your
vehicle and uh,
and it,
and there's no complications.
You can be out of the hospital within
like 48 hours.
Right?
If you have a c section,
they might keep you there from like
three to five days from what I
understand.
Wow.
So it's a lot.
They monitor you because they want to
make sure,
you know,
there's no internal bleeding or problems
with you and the baby.
It just depends on how easy it is.
Pretty incredible how one would just
used to fucking die.
Oh yeah.
It's terrifying.
Oh,
and then what happened was women used to
deliver before the discovery of soap and
washing your hands between delivery.
Women would die on the birthing table
because physicians didn't know to wash
their hands going in there.
Do you mind if I finger you?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
I can't imagine.
I like him.
Like now having a baby.
We don't,
we don't assume that it's risky.
Gender or,
or life threatening.
Yeah,
gender.
Right.
We'd always done it that way.
Don't ever assume a gender are you?
I haven't.
I had an idea for a funny youtube video
and I'm going to.
I don't think I'm going to do it,
but I'm going to tell you guys the idea.
We were going to do it.
You know how people do these,
uh,
gender reveals the balloons and pink and
the blue.
So when we found out the gender,
I was going to do a video on our youtube
channel and the balloons pop and it's
white and I look at the camera.
Go.
How dare you expect me to,
to assume that gender my baby.
Shame on.
I liked it.
I thought it'd be vetoed.
No,
I can't.
Should I start like that?
Funny.
I feel like it's really now.
I thought it had been such a great two
minute.
Little cute little one.
How dare you,
how dare you sick.
You're the pro.
You're everything wrong.
Well,
now are you the kind of people that
you're gonna wait until you have it to
know the gender or do you want to know?
I always wanted to
the thing too,
because you see couples in the,
in the,
uh,
in the hospital posing with the baby,
I always fantasize that in the room,
next door was like a black family and
that I was allowed that they would let
me
close,
but be like,
really disappointed dude.
Definitely somebody else.
Let me tell you,
I had a lactation consultant,
that's another thing.
And they come around and make sure
you're eating well and squeeze and
squeeze those tits.
Slap.
Okay.
And she told me that she goes today at a
pretty crazy day.
I go,
what happened?
She goes,
the baby came out and it wasn't the same
color as both the parents.
Absolutely.
And so they did that.
Yeah.
They did a paternity test for that in
our children.
They look like you.
The older boy looks just like you say
you ask for paternity.
Yeah.
When I was,
I was like,
this guy looks just like you don't see
any me in this system.
Since David fucked up things in the
world though,
a woman like raises someone else's dudes
child.
We imagine being like actively less.
The thing is like for that lady,
possibly she was actively probably,
let's say,
trying to get pregnant.
I was like,
oh,
I'll just hop on one other dixie.
What happens there too?
That has been cheating like that.
I guess it's got to happen both ways,
but she had to know that there was a
chance that was gonna be a black baby.
She's like,
please God,
please don't tell you that.
No,
no,
no.
The doctor is like,
you've got a black baby during delivery.
I'm sure.
It's like everyone's like,
oh,
right,
and they're like cheered,
and then they're like,
oh,
why is it so quiet?
But all the little things,
like when we had the first ultrasound
that doctors like we can do screening or
with new invasive testing or we put a
needle and we squeezed and I was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
don't do blood.
No,
they can do it.
It's amazing.
What he said is this.
I was like,
well,
why would I want to do that?
The screening is 95 percent certain and
then I guess the invasive testing is 90.
Is it certain?
I'll take the.
Yeah,
but there's even,
it's expensive,
but there's,
there's blood tests now that the
screening is unbelief.
They could do it within 10 days.
I wouldn't,
I give,
given that option.
Was it like ridiculous?
It's called Tara.
That's what we had.
I think you're on 12 weeks or 14 weeks.
They do,
they take like 15 vials of blood can
tell you everything,
man.
I'm to color their pubes are going to be
in this basement,
will have red pubes aboard.
Oh,
that was another fun one.
If you have like a fun doctor where you
can ask,
uh,
you know,
I'm like,
so what happens?
Because they go through,
you know,
oh,
your test came back and there's no
genetic markers for anything that you
would worry about.
And I'm like,
so how often do people flush?
And he's like,
well,
you know,
happens sometimes it's for something
like really serious,
like we'll tell them this is like a
major genetic defect because like
sometimes it'll be like not a health
threat will be like,
you know,
I don't know,
like an extra finger yet.
There'll be like,
just abort it.
And he's like,
are you sure?
They're like,
yeah,
yeah.
They're like,
Nah,
it's too weird.
He tells me.
That's crazy.
That is.
So the thing is he's got a big ear lobe.
They're like,
why don't you flush that out?
That we'll start over,
don't want.
Oh my God.
That's how some people are color the
eyes.
Brown Brown.
Like my shit.
Like when I Shit actually what's working
the most likely have blue eyed babies
because Eli has blue eyes and my dad has
blue eyes.
That doesn't that mean 75 percent.
I don't know.
I forget how that shit works.
I'm alerted in 10th grade because the
pool is recessive,
but it's so dominant because the brown
always wins out.
But there's a.
You know what?
If she has blue,
blue,
and her line,
then that becomes dominant.
I'm assuming your dad didn't have blue
eyes.
He had like Hazel Brown,
Hazel.
I know that blue light angels have blue
eyes.
And I know that blue angels,
blue angels had fluid like a tough biker
gang eyes.
You guys want to rob this place?
Let me see your eyes.
Your doctor.
You trust your doctor and stuff.
Um,
and I don't know.
It's like a new dog there.
He seemed cool,
some cool,
but I don't have a background with him.
Kaiser.
Okay.
He seemed nice though.
He got,
he had a nice little joke.
He was like,
uh,
I've been doing this for 12 years and
you could trust me when I say it.
You are pregnant.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Well,
if you don't like him,
definitely now's the time to judge
because he's going to be with you at one
of the craziest moments of your life.
But if you don't,
who does the delivery part?
Your ob really generally.
But there is a possibility that your ob
would not be an extensible,
but most likely they'll know what
they're doing.
Yeah,
I figure but he will have the,
a front row seat to the front row seat.
Did you don't see that deal?
What the everything.
I mean the like the act,
the badge blessed when the grenade went
off and watching that exact moment.
But like I watched that thing,
you know,
I watched the air pump into it and I
watched it swell,
like air pumping because when you start,
when the baby starts coming out right
there,
you see pressure forming down there and
then you see after a while you just see
hair coming out.
It's the scalp,
like the babies and then you see it push
through a little more.
Feel that there's pressure there.
It's like a giant balloon is going like
up and then.
So I'm like this about to pop.
I don't want to see the pop was
there.
No,
not really,
but there is a lot of moments where it
finally clears and like all the fluid.
And so let me,
let me pay you your by her side,
like fire head and then you would like
peek,
like how does it feel like.
So if a,
her head's here.
Yeah,
there's one leg.
This,
this mic arm is her leg.
I'm holding the leg here and I got her
foot here in this elbow and leaning back
with it.
You can take a peek.
Yeah.
So you go like that and you're like,
oh shit,
everything's good.
You don't feel it.
If you have an epidural,
it doesn't matter.
Whatever you do,
don't look at my face.
And then the doctor,
he said,
we can like handfuls of Lube and he's
like losing the baby up.
No,
he's,
he's lubing the rim,
like these luminous.
And he goes and he's like,
oh my goodness.
I felt like he would push it around the
baby's hat making,
try to get the hell out so that.
And also just like stretching it cut my
badge because it was just so snotty.
And so I have so many questions.
What do you remember from that?
Remember that I got to get some of this
to put it.
He took out a bunch of great.
Tom had like this whole deal and there's
a lot going on that you don't remember.
Do you remember?
Just like lots of pushing.
I remember everything.
You're not out of it.
You're not mentally out of it with the
epidural.
You're just physically,
physically you're late.
Can't move your legs and stuff.
So they put your legs in stirrups when
go time now remember everything you just
pushed.
You pushed and lots.
Well they,
they like to wait until you're at the
right at the head.
Right?
You know,
right at the very end.
Yeah.
And you just,
you push like you're shitting.
I'm constipated or it's like a good shit
just keeps coming out.
That's interesting.
No it,
yeah,
it feels like a shit that won't come out
and then all of a sudden like you feel
the head like he's talking about that
moment where the hair and then all of a
sudden like you feel that pop like that.
I've had shifts like that and then the
shoulders and once,
once they turn it and the shoulders come
out of you,
it just goes boom.
The baby like shoes out of you and you
literally just like in a ball in a ball
and,
and all that shit comes out like you
said.
But it's crazy because you feel
everything come out of you in that
second year.
Like,
like it's so jarring.
It's unlike anything.
It's not like taking a shit because it's
literally like your insights are coming
out of you and he wants and it's not
painful.
I don't mean to scare you.
It's not painful.
It's just,
it's unlike anything else.
Listen,
I went back for a second so it can't be
that the baby came.
Oh my God.
You're like,
yeah,
you'll get emotional for sure.
Why?
I mean,
because you're like my life,
so why do you even care?
And then,
and then.
So I was gonna say cut your.
So they kept the name of that premium of
the premium it has showed.
Is there a fun?
Is that what it showed?
Is the skin between the vag called?
What's it called when they called?
It showed.
It showed ectomy.
So how was the,
how has it healed if you get a to be
Calamari?
It's actually.
So here's the deal.
The first one,
the first one I had,
it didn't heal great because she
stitched it up kind of funkily.
So it healed.
It hurt the scar hurt for a long time,
but the second time around I told to my
doctor about it and then he sewed it up
perfectly and now I don't even know what
was it you said to the doctor because I
want,
I want,
I want to or want to know that I can ask
for it to get.
Make sure you stitched up right?
What did you say to the document?
I said whoever the fuck did it the first
time I fucked it up.
Say That to tender.
Whatever.
Fuck.
Whoever you want.
You want to ask if he.
I don't know,
because you might not need an a Pz
atomy.
You might be.
You might tear a little bit.
If you do badge,
he might need a csection.
Who knows?
Ask Him if he does a PCI enemies and how
has the stitching world say what if he's
like,
I'm going to have done them.
I'm not the best,
but we'll do it.
He wants someone talked to women that if
you can,
that have gone to him or ask women.
Yeah.
That have delivered with.
Well you just get recommended like,
yeah,
but you're with Kaiser.
Kaiser Shit.
I mean he seems.
He seems nice.
He's a young guy,
which I like.
He's not like an old fucking guy.
Yeah,
he's probably like 40.
He's Asian.
I realized that of course.
That's interesting.
So he was going to be actually doing the
switch to him then he's gonna yeah,
I think so.
He'll pop in at the last hour and be
like,
alright yeah,
that's.
Oh,
and by the way,
the doctor doesn't come in until the
very end.
So you'll be like pushing and you're
like,
where the fuck is he?
And he's in the hallway or her and
they'll call her and there's that one
nurse.
What are the color?
Who's like in charge of the whole thing
is,
is there a name for it?
Oh,
I don't know,
but there's always a nurse with a lot of
personality.
For some reason we had them twice.
There's someone who's like shecky greene
and they find out you're a comedian.
It's fucking over.
And Tom and I are not shucky Shucky
ducky all the time.
Especially when you're having a child.
Definitely if they ask you what you guys
do like I'm going to count and I,
oh,
I always usually just say something like
video production regardless because I
don't ever want to know what you should
do,
but what do I do?
And then just pull up your youtube
account.
Check this out right here for
production.
Hashtag Hashtag.
Do you guys like it?
It's weird.
I avoid it.
It's also like in the delivery room,
it's like,
it's the worst time also,
you know,
if you're going like,
this is to me,
this isn't like the loose left moment in
someone's life
and they start working their personality
into you and I do that thing where I
just ignore.
I feel them trying to be acknowledged
and I'm just like,
yeah,
I'm not going to acknowledge you.
So I just,
I mean it bothers me,
you know,
I mean,
you,
you gotta do what you got it.
Yeah.
I ignored her and,
and in hindsight I should've been like
someone get fucking shecky greene out of
my delivery room.
I should've just demanded it,
but I didn't want to be able to.
How did they find out?
You guys are comedians.
They fucking someone'll tell someone
will someone will have one nurse at the
station will be like,
that's from the thing and then tell all
the nurses and the nurses are like,
oh,
we got ourselves a little celebrity
here,
Huh?
People I think,
which is what we're looking for when we
don't think people would ever guess some
entertainer or a comedian because I
think I'm really very introverted out in
the.
It might not guess,
but all you gotta do is have the guy
wheeling the meal to somebody's room
walked by and that's what you think.
Well,
they go that and people are like,
who the fuck?
What does that mean?
Right.
But then he'll,
he'll be like,
you don't understand,
and then have you not seen vape.
Fucking it'll go from there.
All of a sudden they'll be like,
we were watching your guys' videos last
night.
Are you dilated?
And you know which one I didn't like
hearing criticism.
You'll be like,
thank you.
I look for.
That's what I wanted right now.
I look for criticism everywhere.
I can get it.
Yeah.
Oh,
take a tour of the hospital before you
give birth,
like do it in your second trimester when
you're not huge and modeling so you know
what to do when you know the go time and
early register,
early registration,
then your pants.
What does that mean?
That means like when you actually,
you can go in,
you can register at the hospital for
like,
you don't have all your information.
Here's your name,
address,
this is your insurance,
everything,
and then there'll be low.
That maternity.
Then when you come in you go like,
we already registered.
They're like,
oh yeah,
take her up.
Arrive.
And they're like,
fill out everything.
Six.
When we came in I was in labor the first
kid and they're like,
sit down,
fill out paperwork,
does she want to do it?
And I was like,
fuck no,
like I'm having contractions right now.
Fill out.
They'll like not let people down the
hall,
you know,
he's all yours.
Wow.
Okay.
That's a hot tip.
Yeah.
Well I'm excited.
I,
seriously,
I'm amazed and I'll tell you too,
it's kind of weird because there's life
before children,
BC and you're like,
I can't,
I don't even remember what the fuck we
did before we had kids right at this
point.
No,
all that free time.
Does it give you a life for me?
If feel purposeful?
Of course you have to be a total fucking
psycho to not think that I talked to
somebody who was like that who I was
like,
nothing's different,
right?
Like he was like,
I go with your life was meaningless
bullshit before.
He's like,
no,
it wasn't like,
Oh yes it was.
And he was like,
why would you say that you have a
fucking one year old.
You don't understand what
I'm saying.
Like I wasn't meaning it all.
Yeah.
He was like,
don't be one of those.
I was like,
dude,
you,
you now are responsible for someone's
life you're talking about.
Yeah.
I just remembered the guy who is telling
us to not have kids to a and Oh my God.
Oh my God,
what a psycho.
This guy,
we went to Sweden.
We don't know him personally,
but he was like,
they're a friend of a friend.
How long have you guys fucked?
He's like away from his family traveling
all the time.
He's like,
don't have kids,
but at any rate I was like,
okay,
whatever.
I don't care about you.
I didn't take it seriously in a
conversation.
You'll never have like,
I've never heard anyone be like I have
a.
because like honestly I don't really
like them.
Wait,
Burke told you this.
It was great.
Well,
I will say if you enjoy having a dog and
I know that a dog and a child is not the
same kind of similar.
Similar why I'm so excited because
shredder,
like I have so much love for him and
like I see him as a person.
He's like the heart and that's,
that's why I'm so excited.
What else?
We also weren't thinking like what was
my life before I read it now it's all
about all you want to walk in all day
and that's why I just love.
I've been thinking so much about what it
is to be apparent.
It's so weird.
It's really such an important kind of
rite of passage as a person,
right,
because you have to think about who you
are as a person,
that who you want this person to be,
what kind of person do you want to be
for them,
and the other thing on top of everything
you're saying is you do have those
moments where you really start thinking
about your parents in a different
capacity because you're like,
oh,
they did all this shit.
And then you realize like,
oh,
I think you got a lot of forgiveness
because you go like,
they were just trying to get you this
chair,
you know,
and they,
whatever they messed up,
they didn't try to mess it up.
Yeah.
Well you realize how shitty your parents
were saying.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean they really dropped the ball
here.
I mean,
that can happen too if they really.
But it is really amazing how much of a
life change it seems.
That will be the biggest thing is I
think that sense of responsibility of
caring for another human being.
It's transformative.
I can tell you until I,
at least until I went through it,
I didn't feel like a real adult until
you're your everyday you wake up and
because you're alive.
That little dudes,
those two dudes were alive,
you know,
and there's levels to this shit.
He don't say shit.
Oh,
dog is like,
you know,
there's like getting a job.
Do you remember like when you,
I don't know what if you,
when you remember getting like a
retirement account,
you have a retirement account.
It feels like an adult thing.
Buying a house is like the big thing.
You feel like an adult,
but nothing ever feels as big as being
like I have a kid who I'm responsible
for everything.
That is the most adult move ever.
For sure.
Why is it human nature is so fucked up
because you're supposed to have a kid at
like 16,
17,
18,
and then if I had a kid at that age I
would fucking ruin that kid's life.
But now I feel like we're in a good
place in our thirties,
early thirties,
but in nature that's kind of like a
death wish.
Delicate at that age you're going to
happen
kid in what?
In college and you'll be fifth.
I always through the college math.
What you you're like,
oh,
I'll be I kid.
Well I'll be,
I'll be,
I'll be 49.
That's,
that's pretty good.
I'll be under 50 when they started
college.
That's crazy.
That's good.
Right?
We're going to be like with canes.
Well how do you get them when one starts
to college?
So I was 38 when I had ellis.
Right?
Or 39 when it's already seven year
difference with either or eight year.
You're 30 right?
Or you'll be 31.
Yeah.
And now I'm 42.
I was yeah,
I just turned 42 when I had Julian
second baby.
So I'm old ass Mama.
No,
but you,
I feel like.
I do think that you guys are going to
be,
are much better parents in a way when
you older and you're more secure,
you've been around,
you have so much more to offer your kid.
Yeah,
that's true.
People losing like younger parents,
not really getting like,
dude,
if you lose your shit on that kid right
now,
that's not really the way to parent.
They soak everything because you're so
triggered up and you don't,
you don't know.
You don't have that experience of life
to be like,
oh,
this is just a trigger.
This is a childhood thing.
This is a thing.
This isn't about him.
This is about what happened back here.
You know,
it's a lot of your past and your present
and everything merges.
Well.
I had been thinking a lot about that
stuff since I started therapy because
it's all about like your family and
asked and big time and I stuff I never
thought about before.
But,
but you seem happier.
I think you've.
Do you feel better or a little more
relief?
Or has it started yet?
Um,
well I've been doing.
I've been doing as much as I can kind of
have to deal with the depression.
I started taking antidepressants about.
I haven't said that publicly because
that's kind of waiting to see.
I do.
I did want to talk about it publicly
because I think it's important for
people to know what it is because I had
such a huge misconception of what it is,
but I think I've been on it for like two
months now and it definitely helps a
lot.
That's great.
Like it's great.
It's great that you made a decision to
do that and that it's working well.
I kinda hit a wall where I was like,
uh,
anything other than this.
I was putting off it for so long ago,
but then I was just like,
you know,
anything other than whatever this is now
and,
but actually it's not,
it's really,
it's really quite subtle.
The first two weeks is really tough
because you've,
you feel it and it's confusing and you
don't know what you're.
And
you feel the side effects a lot.
You can have a headache and you cannot
sleep well.
And you.
My thing was I was feeling like foggy in
my brain.
That was super frustrating.
Just like the first couple of weeks on
the medication,
starting the meds and then what it kind
of just evens out.
Yeah.
And then I started to feel,
are you okay?
Are you on a time crunch?
You guys got to bounce and go somewhere
soon.
It's been a good time.
It's been such a fantastic.
It's like a real great moment to bring.
Thank you.
I was really.
Actually,
this has been a long.
That's where will see we could.
It wasn't this.
We could have kept talking for over.
Yeah,
we definitely could have,
but you guys are mommies and daddies as
I'm,
I'm really happy,
man.
That,
that you're feeling better and that has
worked well for you.
I'm still,
I'm still miserable.
Okay.
I'm still depressed,
but I'll say this.
And I said it's an the other day.
The difference now is that there's a
light at the end of the tunnel.
That's great.
That's all it needs to be.
I feel like there's hope and I can see a
way out of it and don't be one of these
fucking guys that goes like,
no,
I'm done taking it like a um,
don't be that guy.
Well and was saying is I'm taking that.
I'm exercising and I'm doing therapy.
Right.
That's like all the things that they say
are good and you're tracking it every
day.
Yeah.
I don't know if that helps,
but I'm pretty sure they tell you to
jack off a lot.
Well,
to say to that,
reaching out for help is key.
Yes.
Prognosis.
That's you're already the champion.
You're doing what you should be joining.
Yeah,
it feels awesome.
it's been good.
Let me Brag for Tina for a second.
She did her special eight months
pregnant.
You were super pregnant and all the
promos and stuff.
It's amazing.
I was there.
I remember seeing the Promo video and
they just have you like in a black Jack
Table.
I feel like it's because you couldn't
really walk Ragnar now that you killed
it and it's really great.
It's a really great special.
Everybody fucking degenerate before you
guys leave because I know you are in a
hurry.
I just want to urge everybody watching
who ha everyone has netflix.
We have no excuse to go on over there
tonight.
Today,
this weekend put on the Git,
generates the Gen Z,
right?
There's six parts.
Your number six,
so watch six.
God bless everyone else,
but watch six credit lines are all
great,
but Nika Sanders,
sanders,
Lisa trigger Brad Williams,
who's been a guest on your mom's house
and big Jay Oakerson and myself.
So it's a killer.
It's so much fun in Vegas and downtown
Vegas,
the seediest of all places.
I'm eight months pregnant.
I had a door fall on me a second.
Sorry.
The collapse.
Oh Wow.
There crazy.
It was crazy.
So yes,
it's great.
It's great.
A,
what is it?
A week from Friday?
My,
uh,
I'm in a movie called the instant
family.
Yeah.
So cool.
That's great man.
We,
we saw it together,
went to a screening together.
It starts Mark Walberg,
Rose Byrne.
It's like a big family comedy,
but it's really.
Well,
but it's November 16th,
November 16th.
I cannot wait to.
Yeah,
very,
very.
This is your first feature.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's exciting.
It was very excited.
It was very fun thing and it's like a
major movie.
It's not just like a piece of shit.
Do you have a lot of screentime in it?
I probably have like,
I don't know,
somewhere between seven and 10 seats.
You know,
it's like a supporting character.
I mean there's 50 scenes in the movie I
can think in a lot of.
I would love to see you and more role
that.
It was fun.
I thought I even in the trailer I was
like,
I love this.
I had a good time doing it and I had A.
I mean I'm with like all stars man,
like really real Wahlberg Wahlberg,
who's a huge movie star at Roseburg,
this amazing actress.
But then like all the supporting cast,
like Margo Martindale from the Americans
and sneaky Pete and Julie Haggerty.
It's like,
it's really good act.
That's awesome.
I can't wait to watch it.
I'm super excited and of course guys,
if you want to watch these two on tour,
which you should want to snap,
get on over to Christina p online.com.
Just announced the tour ride or die
tour,
right or die.
My dudes online.com.
And of course Thompson [inaudible] dot
com slash tour.
Your l is a little hard to say on the
tour page.
It's like for you,
I,
I wanted to say your tour Europe,
but it's like toward dash two or of a
strange check.
I'm going to yell at someone,
but anyway you'll find it a Christina p
online.com
and Tom Score Dot com tour.
Loved these two.
We love you guys and of course your
mom's house podcast guys,
which is available everywhere,
chloride out,
which is one of the premier podcast.
If you want to see these two were on it
on an episode,
watch that episode when we definitely
have the podcast.
Obviously more,
but let's do it.
Let's put a dinner on the book soon.
I was just starting to get their period
therapeutic use of hanging out with you
guys.
I know we have to do this again.
Maybe you come back to our dump.
Hashtag got a good time with Jaret.
Kayla,
you're in.
I love the.
I can't believe this guy understands
social media.
Had a good time here.
I had a really good time.
All right.
Thank you everybody for watching.
Have a blessed week and a blessed
weekend.
We appreciate you.
We love you so much and a special thank
you to this excellent dudes Netflix,
get the F on it and put on degenerates
this weekend.
Thank you so much.
We shall see you next Friday at our
usual time.
Uh,
thanks for watching.